bonsoir
bonsoir à tous merci de cet accueil
c'est incroyable d'être ici ce soir
sachez que je suis super ému d'être ici
parmi vous quand j'étais petit je
regardais les césar sur les genoux de ma
mère justement me disant un jour moi
aussi j'y serai je t'ai qu'un môme
impressionné le pouce dans la bouche
le doudou serré contre le coeur un gamin
qui avait le droit de veiller tard ce
soir là je m'en rappellerai toute ma vie
c'était les césar 2011
franchement c'est tellement dingue
d'être ici vous n'en voulez pas si je
fais une une petite photo de l'assemblée
juste vite fait ces tubes bien venir
avec moi si vous voulez peut-être mettre
vraiment en l'air non je déconne je
déconne ce ça va pas être crédibles
auprès pour l'être pour l'académie ok
merci pour l'ambiance
je vais la poster tout de suite en
mettant voilà ce que je vois maintenant
maintenant une photo de ce qui
m'intéresse vraiment maintenant
salue monsieur si vous pouvez dire à
scarlett qu'on se voie après haïti aux
afters au dîner des césars de caesar
salad monsieur tarantino je voulais
simplement vous dire que je suis un
grand fan je pourrais également une
petite photo de vous voilà vraiment un
énorme fan vous franchement vous êtes un
génie vous tuez tous pas y voir jean us
uk oubliant juste en tout cas voilà
saint-servan messieurs dames
merci du fond du coeur à tous de m'avoir
invité ce soir c'est un truc de malade
pour moi d'être ici et ça a du sens
parce qu'on me dit toujours tes
l'humoriste des enfants des ados tu fais
rire que les enfants que les ados là
pour une fois c'est l'occasion de faire
un truc pour les adultes quoi c'est top
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on m'a
confié la mission de remettre le césar
du meilleur dessin animé